water is life but now we're turning off
the faucet
no more water for you
if you stopped drinking water what would
happen to your organs
how long until you turn into a piece of
human jerky
and why would you drink your own pee
no really why would you do that stop
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you stopped drinking water
does more than power life it's the
majority of you humans are 50 to 70
percent water
this liquid helps structure your body on
a microscopic level creating cells and
fueling their chemical reactions to
deliver nutrients
on this planet and in your life nothing
would be possible without good old H2O
so what if you went cold turkey and
stopped drinking water for good
how would your organs react
giving up water would be a death
sentence but before you turn into a pile
of dust your body will go through some
other radical changes
in the first few hours your thirst would
be minor this would be the easy part
throughout this whole process you'd need
to slow down and take it easy you don't
want to sweat out the water left in you
you need every drop of this precious
substance
and your body knows that too your organs
would hold on tight to the water inside
you
that means your kidneys would stop
sending as much water to your bladder
causing you to pee much less
and without water in your cells to help
move nutrients your blood would become
thick and sluggish
over the next two days your heart rate
would increase rapidly to maintain
normal oxygen levels your body would be
fighting to stay alive
by day three four percent of your body
weight would disappear but
you aren't looking good
your blood would become so thick and
concentrated that your skin would
shrivel up like a raisin
since you don't have any more water to
sweat out the smallest amount of heat
could overwhelm your system
and with your blood pressure falling you
would struggle to stay conscious
if you think now you may want to stay
asleep that way you could avoid the Real
Pain about to come
on day four without water non-vital
organs like your kidneys and gut would
be receiving very little blood
cellular waste would build up in your
system and those toxins would make your
muscles sensitive and inflamed every
move would have you reeling in agony
you'd be so dehydrated that the simplest
tasks would be impossible as your brain
would slowly be losing cognitive
function
ah you're so thirsty and exhausted
should you I don't know drink your own
pee to stay alive
no no again stop that's not going to
help
at this point your urine would be so
filled with waste that your body would
have to work even harder to filter it
every liquid in your body would now be a
toxic slurry slowly poisoning you
by day five you'd have lost 10 percent
of your body weight in water your liver
would be about to stop working entirely
and the rest of your organs would be
reaching critically hot temperatures
and at this point you likely haven't had
a bowel movement in days
wait what
well all this time your large intestine
was soaking up any water that was left
leaving you constipated
the cartilage in your joints would be so
dry that it would be hard to move even
an inch
at this point you'd be regretting this
awful decision I mean if you were still
alive
so how can you recover
yeah you'd have to check into a hospital
fast
doctors would need to rehydrate your
body with an IV in order to get
electrolytes and sugar back into your
system
in about two to three days you can
recover from this extreme but the damage
might last a lifetime
yeah your kidneys would be shot and
possibly diseased and you'd have urinary
tract infections
you might even have to live the rest of
your life with hypertension and
intestinal failure
dehydration is a serious problem that
could lead to startling chronic health
problems
but what if you went overboard in your
recovery
what if you only drank water for the
rest of your life
well stay right here because
that's a story
for another
what if